aber mein name ist nobody herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf meinem
plan und ihr seht es hier oben schon
eingeblendet werden video
ja da kann immer klatschen beim einem
content bekomme ich doch noch deals am
start
ja das ist einfach wahnsinn das heutige
video wird unterstützt von age legends
dass er bin ich und ich zeige peace
weltfrieden die fiesen wild frontier ist
nämlich ab sofort verfügbar und es gibt
auch eine wette pass bundle mit über 100
einzigartige items
doch ich bin übrigens lifeline der hat
die neue legende
es gibt nämlich im rahmen der season one
wild frontier nun auch eine neue legende
babe hexe namens octane und zwar ist das
ein sehr geschwindigkeit safina
charakter sage ich mal mit einer jump
hätte bildet hier also der kann einfach
sein jump for sich schmeißen und springt
dann hoch in die luft trägerkreis auf
jeden fall
wir sind hier gerade schon in der luft
und landen jetzt vielleicht irgendwo
allerdings seht ihr die challenge ja
schon im titel eingeblendet hier spielen
natürlich nicht normal apex sondern
haben eine challenge am start
ich werde mit meinen händen
überkreuzspielen die ganze zeit lang
geht nicht meine rechte hand an der maus
sein um einen link und einer tastatur
sondern rechts an der tastatur und links
an der maus das heißt ihr seht mich
jetzt in der fans kam so ein bisschen
komisch eingeblendet ich bin so ein
bisschen halt mit meinen armen grad so
über kreuz und im spiel sieht komisch
aus wie ich mich glaube ich hin und her
bewegen wenn ich dann schnell so ich
musste gerade checken wie ich an die
shift taste mit meinen fingern komme das
ist genauso wie mit dingen wie ich muss
mit meinem kleinen finger die leertaste
bedienen das ist genauso wie wenn man
sich beispielsweise mal den arm
gebrochen hat und dann muss man sich
plötzlich mit links die zähne putzen
das ist es geht nicht immer hier hoch
jetzt hier und ich schaffe es nicht mal
eine treppe zulauf wie solchen etwas
spiel gewählt das wichtigste ist erstmal
dass wir die zone kommen das heißt ich
drück jetzt m und ja wir sind gar nicht
mal so weit entfernt viel wichtiger als
die zone ist allerdings gerade erst mal
eine waffe und zwar muss ich schauen ob
ich kann ich hier rein ja okay ist das
scheiße ich muss gegend wo eine waffe
finden hier vorne liegt so eine kapsel
rum das heißt ich kann einfach jeder
rücken
zoe schwere munition und für welche
waffe melden hieß es muss irgendwie ganz
schnell an etwas rankommen mit dem ich
mich wehren kann
die sache ist allerdings wie soll ich
mich dann wären alter ich spiele so
egal jedoch in die tür eine waffe so
angucken und also ich drücke jetzt hier
und habe eine waffe die sache ist jetzt
ich muss mit dem zeigefinger die rechte
muss ist okay das ist zu kompliziert
hier vorne haben wir noch ein körper
spielt den gönne ich mir auch erst mal
das ist wichtig wir haben noch leichte
munition
die haben wir auch noch leichter
munition hier haben wir noch eine b 20
20 darf ich ja erst ab nächstem jahr
benutzten die schwere munition den wir
auch noch mit ich wechsele mal wieder
auf meine flat line und werde nun hier
wo ist noch mal froidevaux sei die ach
du heilige scheiße haben ja richtig
verlassen laufen wir jemals ein bisschen
durch die wüste durch m der typ hat da
hinten auf jeden fall so einen ort hin
gesagt mein gott dessen gegner
achtung kacke erst tote muss ich mir
überlegen was mache ich denn jetzt ein
paar sekunden später
ich will erst mal ein bisschen beide
sind tatsächlich gerade ist aber nicht
schlimm ich kann euch retten hat jetzt
nicht so gut geklappt ich meine man hat
keinen platz neun von 20 neue runde
neues glück ja genau
er hat auch schon den neuen charakter
der sohn eines aus er hat auch einfach
schon 28 kills und ich bin in dieser
runde gerade der jump master das heißt
freunde ich sehe uns erstmal dass wir
hier hingehen maschen ist mein da bin
ich geboren also freude da vorne wollen
wir hin das heißt ich bin jetzt mal raus
und alle folgen mir rechte kingsley der
ja kein wegen verlassen mich ruhig liegt
aber trotzdem an meinen freunden hier
hinterher weil ich glaube alleine mit
dieser challenge über dem ich nicht so
lange so die rechte hand ist mal wieder
einer tastatur die linke hand des
anderem aus das heißt ich werde jetzt
mal ganz schnell hier dem song pro clara
der song klarer welche meter heraus
nämlich nicht weil hier oben ist noch
einer kiste da schaue ich mal direkt
rein und wir haben keine waffe super
danke in bogen stern mit dem ach du mein
leben heilige mutter gottes was geht da
ab also der bogen stern scheint schon
krass zu sein
ich gehe zurück hier so die munition gar
nicht was habe ich getan
was habe ich getan ich glaube das ist
eben seine fähigkeit oder so vor wie
hier unten liegt auf jeden fall eine
waffe kommen egal
bis hier nach rechts zurück da altherren
nato alter nato die sommer clara ist da
hinten
ich mache immer noch weiter meine
challenge hey hallo
kannst du mich mal hallo wir sind in
einem team das nur mal hallo 2000 jahre
später verstehen
[Musik]
ich habe keine munition mehr schwimmen
gehen da warten auf abholung haye kam
ich dann meiner retten vielleicht ja
freunde wäre echt nett wenn ihr mich mal
retten würde
diesmal spiele ich bangalore ist meine
zweite liebe wie sagt der 32 bit und ich
nun wirklich alle sowie business leute
los gehe jetzt hätten wir mal wieder
über kreuz sowieso schon raus gesprungen
der typ will also direkt butter bei die
fische backen glaube ich kommt
eigentlich dieses sprichwort butter bei
die fische ries frage will ich nicht wir
sind direkt hier online
ich bin kein schaden bekommt ok cool das
ist die erste runde der ich mich nicht
selbst verletzte schauen wir mal was wir
hier vorne haben hier ist ein körper
stellt das kann ich auf jeden fall
gebrauchen da schauen was wir hier haben
wir liegen auf jeden fall waffe herum
das heißt ich guck mich jemand ein
bisschen oben und so weiter so ob ich
habe wieder irgendwas los geschossen
glaube ich habe die nicht ruhig alles
easy pack ich ein paar sachen liegen
gelassen meine guten freunde in einem
spot damit ihr seid ihr heute
jetzt ab welche extra sachen gegeben das
war es wirklich komplett freunde aber
gut weiter geht's freunde
ich würde sagen wir holen uns jetzt mal
den sieg auf jeden fall in dieser runde
drei einmal stehen
na hallo jetzt kommt doch stehen war die
bobbahn du bist mein freund hey wir sind
in einem spot wir müssen hier zusammen
uns den sieg holen damit wir zwei ein
bisschen schwierig weil ich hallo war
die handy war die dga es kann doch nicht
so schwer europas tut ist vom himmel
gefallen war die jetzt komm mal her hier
es kann doch nicht sein ich glaube ich
habe die beiden hassen mich ist aber
nicht schlimm ich würde mich auch hassen
ich glaube aber die sind wirklich gut in
diesem spiel weil die haben hier schon
die ganze zeit so krasse wege und machen
hier so heftig parkuhren haben so voll
dem plan sind direkt ausgesprochen sich
direkt waffen gekommen jetzt wartet mal
ich kann nicht so schnell danke köhler
es ist ein köder ist der fall
leute kröger ist weg ist aber nicht
weiter schlimm
wir haben noch und freunde tage und was
tut ihr kommen leute ich veganer bleibt
ihr gerade mal stehen sondern lauft
direkt ich arbeite jetzt kann doch nicht
so schwer eine waffe eva ich mal meine
mosambik aus gegen die fao
er hat sogar ein richtig cooles design
also mal schauen was hier vorne abgeht
da sind auf jeden fall gegner brachte
packe ich gehe mal war die blaue ding
rein das sieht gut aus
wie soll ich das doch machen so ja wir
sind wir alle tot
auf jeden fall der hammer runde
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren apex legions hat mich einfach
gefragt hey luca eben sehen dass das
spiel schon immer auf seinem kanal
gespielt und es kam gut an deswegen
hättest du nicht bock dafür dass jetzt
der neue season one battle pass raus ist
holt ihr euch lieber schnell bevor die
season vorbei ist im rahmen der neuen
season one wild frontier hat sich
extensions einfach gefragt hey luca wie
finde ich cool denkt die eben eine coole
challenge ausmachen lustiges video zu
dem spiel genau dynasty und ich hab
gesagt klar in einem korb feiere ich
mega als jeder spieler max legions noch
nicht haben sollte und haltet euch
gefallen haben sollte dann download ist
auf jeden fall spielen gerade mehr als
50 millionen spieler für 50 millionen
spieler das spiel ist übrigens kostenlos
ihr findet den link und in der
beschreibung ist kein geld ausgeben wenn
ihr das ganze spielt also schaut euch
auf jeden fall mal an wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat würde ich mich
natürlich sehr aber einen daumen hoch
von euch freuen schreibt mir gerne und
in die kommentare was eure lieblings
legende ist bei apax legions und nochmal
danke schön an ipex legends dafür dass
sie dieses video hier unterstützt haben
[Musik]